habt ihr schon mal crumble mit Kürbis
und Apfel probiert falls nein dann macht
dieses Rezept nach ich mache jetzt hier
meine klassischen crumble nehme dafür
aber auch Haferflocken mit dem Mehl mit
dazu dann nehme ich einen Hokkaido
Kürbis den schneide ich in feine Würfel
Äpfel kommen dazu Zitronensaft ein paar
Schokodrops Vanilleextrakt dann kommen
die crumble oben drauf gerne noch ein
bisschen schokotrops drüber streuen und
im Ofen backen und am besten serviert
ihr dann das crumble einfach noch warm
mit etwas gehe Sesampaste und bei Bedarf
noch etwas Zimtzucker drüber streuen
guten Appetit